Next question today is about the economy.
David, how is Donald Trump still polling better
than Joe Biden on the economy?
This is a really good question.
And it gets to a lot of the way that Republicans
have operated for a very long time.
You've got a recession going on.
Trump is down eight, nine, 10, 12 points nationally
to Joe Biden.
And yet he is still polling better than Biden
on the economy.
Morning consult has Trump plus nine on the
economy.
CNN has Trump plus 12 on the economy.
You gov.
Has Trump plus five.
Quinnipiac says Biden is plus one on the economy.
But that's way less than on basically every
other issue for Biden.
Harvard Harris poll says Trump is plus 10
on the economy.
So a couple of different things.
Number one, the the lead is diminishing.
So if you look at the trend line, Trump is
leading Biden by less and less on handling
the economy over time.
There is a meme, there's a tendency to think
that Republicans are just better on the economy
than Democrats.
Now, the reality is that that's a historical
we did a analysis, we did an analysis earlier
this week about the stock market under Democrats
versus Republicans.
Does far better under Democrats than other
Republicans.
Unemployment tends to be lower.
We've looked at all the numbers, but in practice,
Trump also doesn't know a damn thing about
the economy.
Trump didn't know about currency valuations.
He called Michael Flynn at 3:00 a.m. and said,
do we want a weak currency or a strong currency?
Which is good?
And Flynn said, talk to an economist.
Trump has no idea on trade.
Trump believes that the stock market tells
us how an economy is doing so.
Part of it is that a lot of voters also think
those same things Trump thinks to figure out
how the economy is doing.
You look at the stock market, a lot of voters
think the same thing.
And in fact, they tweet me all the time and
say the economy's doing great because the
stock market is doing great.
A lot of what also needs to be considered
is that Republicans tend to do things economically
that will have a short term focus.
How many jobs can we create this month, even
though reopening early will hurt the economies
in the long run?
And a lot of the jobs jobs are crappy.
Right.
How many stock market points can we gain today,
even if it's with cash injections that are
short sighted and won't really improve the
economy in the long run?
So that's a really important thing also to
consider, which is Republicans are far more
likely than Democrats to do things that improve
the optics of the economy in the short term,
but don't really improve it in the long term.
And this is where a lot of this translates
into the general belief that Republicans are
just better for your paycheck, you know, better
for your pocketbook or better for your bank
account.
It's mathematically untrue, but unfortunately,
these, Meems, are pretty sticky.
And just remember the fact stocks do better
under Democrats.
Unemployment is lower under Democrats.
Just about every economic indicator.
We've looked at a bunch of others, although
I'm forgetting them now.
They look better under Democrats and we shouldn't
allow them to take the narrative away.
And the diminishing lead that Donald Trump
has on Joe Biden in terms of expected handling
of the economy is a sign that at least the
disastrous economic situation we have right
now is affecting Donald Trump.
We thought maybe he's Teflon, Teflon Don.
Maybe nothing will affect him.
Coronavirus.
The subsequent economic collapse and his reaction
to the protests against police brutality have
hurt him very much.
His approval down to 38 percent.